what Twilight scene made you the most
emotional and one moment on set made
Kristen Stewart say I was so
transcendently weird that day number one
there was real magic in the air that day
the wedding scene was the last part
filmed for Breaking Dawn part one and
Kristen Stewart said that she could
really feel the series coming to its end
not only that but being a fan of the
books she said she got oddly emotional
seeing the scene come together I felt
good that day Christian was apparently
so excited that she wanted to run down
the aisle saying that she was literally
pulling away from Billy Burke ready even
Robert Pattinson noticed telling
Entertainment Weekly I could see her
getting sort of emotionally affected by
it and I almost didn't want to stay at
the end of the aisle I wanted to go down
and say stop being so ridiculous
number two we almost didn't get to see
Robert as Edward Twilight director
Catherine Hardwick admitted that she
wasn't entirely sold on Robert when he
arrived at auditions sharing that Rob
walked in and he had his hair dyed black
for some play with these wacky bangs and
I'm like oh okay let's see how this goes
it was Rob's chemistry with Kristen that
changed Hardwick's mind I just want to
try one thing the two played out the
kissing scene on Hardwick's bed and
according to her Rob was so into it he
fell off the bed afterwards Kristen
insisted that Robert be the one to
perform opposite her as Edward and even
hardwood commented I could tell they had
a lot of chemistry so the lion fell in
love with the lamp number three Taylor
Lautner's shirtless scenes weren't
nearly as fun for him as they were for
us especially when it came to filming
his breakup scene in the rain for New
Moon Taylor admitted that he struggled
with the cold playing werewolf Jacob
Black Taylor wasn't allowed to show any
response to the Cold War water he was
drenched with from an onset rain Tower
and although it only took them about
four minutes to film the scene he had to
redo it several times throughout the day
to push through he had to take myself to
another world so during the scene I
wasn't sitting there shivering between
takes he could take advantage of the
onset blankets and heater but only for
about two minutes before he had to
return number four you kind of have to
feel bad for her Kristen Stewart had
food poisoning the day she shot the tent
scene for Eclipse luckily all she really
had to do was lie there shivering anyway
but Stephanie Meyer who was visiting the
set that day revealed that Kristen was
so sick between takes Taylor Lautner
played the hero that day grabbing her a
garbage can in case she needed to throw
up survival 101 the Twilight writer
recalled that everybody was taking care
of her and everything but it was a hard
day she expressed Sympathy For What the
leading lady had to go through saying
that Kristen's job was so hard as she
had to perform shivering all while
feeling like she needed to throw up
number five you might remember this
scene for how intense it got Robert
Pattinson remembers it for different
reasons he revealed in an interview with
the independent the hardest scene to
fill was probably the birth scene in
Breaking Dawn Part One mainly because it
was hilarious and it was supposed to be
really serious he admitted once that a
Comic-Con panel that he thought the
Scene goes very far which might explain
what he found so funny but he also added
that there was no other way to do it
apparently he was laughing so hard that
he couldn't stop tears from falling
adding that it looks like I'm crying in
the thing he might have been able to use
those tears to his Advantage but playing
Edward Cullen he was not supposed to be
able to cry as a vampire number six just
like any family the cullins didn't
always get along Ashley Greene revealed
in an interview with people that there
were plenty of ups and downs and some
drama between the cast on set as she
pointed out five years is a long time to
spend together without any tips though
she'd add that many of the actors had
been in their 20s at the time so you can
imagine who you were in your 20s versus
who you are now although she didn't give
many details one scuffle we are aware of
was between her and Nikki Reed when the
two were reunited on Ashley Greene's
podcast she expressed that Nikki and I
went back and forth where we were cool
and then we didn't want anything to do
with each other and then we were cool
again number seven being a star isn't as
glamorous as you might think Although
our three leads were all close when
filming began Kristen Stewart would
state in an interview that on the
Twilight sets towards the end I found
that people didn't really talk to us
anymore she said that it felt as though
someone had told the rest of the cast to
avoid her unless they had a reason to
approach going on to say it's like now
you are just completely isolating me so
thanks but the worst part about it for
her was that the rest of the cast might
think she was was the one asking to be
left alone which is like do not
represent me ever overall she summarized
the experience by saying that it was
just really annoying number eight they
seemed like good friends while filming
the first Twilight movie it was clear
that Kristen Stewart and Nikki Reed had
grown close with Nikki even sharing that
Kristen and I are best friends yet when
it came time to film Eclipse feelings
had obviously changed while discussing
her co-star Nikki admitted that they had
been close in the beginning but that
success had changed the dynamic we are
not all best friends and we're not all
going to hang out together after the
final movie is done I don't understand
what I did
this statement only fueled fan rumors
that Robert Pattinson had driven a wedge
between the two friends with some even
suggesting that they may have been
involved in an onset love triangle
although Nikki Reed has denied ever
dating Robert Pattinson number nine it
had to end eventually Robert Pattinson
and Christian Stewart shot their final
scene for Breaking Dawn part two
together but it was far from a special
moment rather Robert would later admit
that he felt a little weird getting so
emotional over the end when there was
only the two of them there and then they
just end it and it's like well okay well
that's that he and Kristen been there
awkward goodbyes but both of them knew
that they'd be seeing each other again
only four months later for the press
release Robert went on to say that he
figured the end of their tour would make
for a harder goodbye I'm really really
curious what it's going to be like the
last day of this tour number 10 he
played The Lone Wolf to the end Taylor
Lautner had a hard time letting go of
the Twilight franchise and to make
matters worse he didn't even have a
chance to give a proper goodbye to his
co-stars in an interview Taylor revealed
that my last day of shooting I was by
myself so that was kind of sad although
his second to last day was spent
shooting a scene with Robert Pattinson
and Kristen Stewart he admitted that it
was a little emotional seeing his
co-stars on set for the last time
emphasizing that it was tough for us
because we had been playing these
characters for so long and spending so
much time together for so long the
Twilight franchise was not an easy
filming process which emotional behind
the scenes story surprised you the most
we'd love to hear your opinions so make
them heard down in the comments